[Music]
so you're gonna do a property twist what
want me tell tell me what your job is
okay my job is actually really cool and
it's one of the best jobs in the world
I look after all of the Academy members
so I see that they're having an amazing
time
it's a national property and I also had
a management winners and I went yeah I
see your windows on a Wednesday Queen
Abby what's your job I buy your
properties two sisters oh so you manage
my life at one point so we're gonna do a
property quiz the best promising expert
is help you to if it was if it was an
exam I'll ask your question if you know
the answer say yes if you don't know say
no and then of just if I don't the sense
that you really do a lot yeah
so the first question is do you guys
both know what a lease option agreement
is yes a lease option agreement is
basically when you agree that you're
buying a property what you're doing in
future do why in the future you'll you
have an option to purchase a property
you can agree on certain price and then
have an option to buy it at like three
to five seven years later when you give
in the market a chance to
very good all right here's one his lunch
do you know when IH mo property needs a
license and when it doesn't I feel um I
remember the number but I know that you
do you're not one of the game every
actually is a license and that's up to
five people after five people you need
planning oh I make sure what did you say
that I thought you didn't need it yeah
they need planning permission over five
Sergey go on like when does it it's all
five people what's that you have to be
fired or more people yes my how many
rooms yeah in the house at some other
people like property creates property
question what typically tell me if you
know the answer don't tell me the answer
if you know the answer so what are
interest rates typically for buy to let
mortgages I feel like I dunno it's
standard mortgage is 25 percent 25
percent is how much deposit you're
putting out straight what I asked you
for yes yeah I know what the interest
rates are for mortgages possibly about
three percent mortgage that must have
been one of our which I can see the
spreadsheet so so far you both got the
license one wrong next question who on
earth
who would who on earth would give you
their house for free on a lease option
agreement are you asking if you know
that says what kind of person would give
you their house but what would be the
criteria of the person that would
qualify for a lease option agreement
what kind of seller would want yeah give
you the house oh yeah yes so what do you
think just to sell their house can't
Sally it's been on the market for a
while and no one going to yeah you're
kind of what do you say
if similar to what Abby said it's
building on so especially people I'm
negative
I think I'll have to give that point to
call them over you know
next question how long typically when
you move a tenant into your house is the
ist contract for the minimum as deikun's
like generally speaking from white slip
properties do you know yeah so do you
know is it mix or years six yeah six
months ruggedized tape okay next
question is what is the definition
telling you the answer of financial
freedom do you guys know the definition
of financial freedom yes you know the
definition out
just sigh ever buy it cuz if I was asked
it I think I'd be able to do but I'd
like end up you know you know the
definition Ali what do you think the
definition might be financial freedom
it's when you can also take a message to
the ultimate oh yeah sure you add say
you got a car club just chop it
something like when your income yeah
call this like your your bills
[Applause]
so I think those of you are experts
investor so on I thought
Oh Jack what is the definition of
financial freedom financial freedom is
where you match the income that was
passive so say if your guiding kind of
life
you know able to pound you know that's
what you'd look for items approaches to
cover those costs you can still work you
can still work if you wanted to it just
means it matches at the amount about
nice nice and well that's better
where doesn't hate other people
licensing it you'll need a licensing you
need five people or more being intent it
also here's a basement or an extra floor
you'll need license five article for any
license funny buddy
say he knows more than me so that was
the property investors quiz and it turns
out everyone's a rock star I hope you're
on our Tartu if not come see me or come
see a beam corner
[Music]